hi there take a look at the following
problem
on the left right here so you have this
quadruped
and the goal is to have it walk forward
or in any direction
as far as possible now usually this is
the
domain of sort of reinforcement learning
so you have inputs which is the
sensors of the joints of the quadruped
and you have outputs which is how much
force you want to put
on each of the legs and you have to
somehow learn a policy to make it walk
forward reinforcement learning does that
by
sort of trial and error using an
environment to learn
the policy directly however this paper
does something different what it does is
it
learns a policy that is adaptive during
training
which basically means that at the
beginning of each episode
the policy in it is initialized randomly
and by policy here we mean a policy
network
uh policy neural network which you can
see at the bottom
so that's initialized randomly and then
during
the episode depending on the input
uh this network is changed and adapted
in order to achieve
high performance so even at test time
the network is started randomly and then
adapted
during the episode so this paper
deals with this problem and tries to
implement this sort of
more biologically plausible way of
learning a policy adapting to the
environment
and achieve ultimately good performance
in this task
and it has some nice property namely
that it can deal
with these things as you can see here
front right leg damage front left leg
damage but
we'll get to that later but just so you
know what's coming
so the paper is called meta learning
through hebbian plasticity
in random networks by elias najaro and
sebastian
rizi so we'll go through the paper what
it does
what evolutionary methods are really
briefly which they use
what hebbian plasticity is and the
difference to classic
reinforcement learning and then we'll
look at the experiments
and that's going to be it if you like
content like this as always don't
hesitate to subscribe and share it out
and tell me what you think in the
comments i still read all the comments
so
i am very interested in what you think
about works like this and about the
video
itself okay so they say lifelong
learning and adaptability are two
defining aspects of biological agents
modern reinforcement learning approaches
have shown significant progress
in solving complex tasks however once
training is concluded
the found solutions are typically static
and
incapable of adapting to new information
or perturbations so they contrast the
two things here
reinforcement learning as you know is
very powerful
in these domains but its goal is to
learn a policy and then that policy is
fixed and
it's specific to that particular problem
however biological agents you know
humans
uh animals and so on they're able to
adapt
usually very very quickly they give some
sort of examples right here like
if a if an animal is born it almost
immediately knows how to walk um so even
if it has some sort of injury
even if it has some sort of disability
um usually
the animal can walk uh pretty much
instantly
and that means it sort of adapts to
the body that it is in sort of
reconfigures itself
on the fly and that's what we're going
to explore here so this isn't going to
out compete uh rl anytime soon
it's just a different way and a
biologically more plausible
way in order to do that so again they
say
we still don't know completely how
biological brains
learn and adapt so efficiently from
experience it is believed that synaptic
plasticity
plays a prominent role in this process
and that's why
they are using these hebien learning
rules
in order to configure the network so
let's contrast the two things for a
second in
reinforcement learning what you have is
a policy network now the policy network
is a neural network that
maps sensory inputs to actions
okay so you have the observation goes in
and out comes in action
this is your policy network now
during training in reinforcement
learning what you do is you have some
sort of environment
okay this is the environment and you
play this back and forth game
with the environment and you try to
improve
this policy network right here as
best as you can in order to achieve a
high reward
then during testing so this is train
then during testing you freeze you
freeze this network right here
so you freeze the network
and then you simply play that game and
you see how well it does
okay so this gives you some sort of
reward and that's going to be your
testing reward and you know that can be
generalization it can be to different
environments and so on but the crucial
part is
that you in train you learn
and then you freeze during test
in this in this particular paper right
here
they do something different so let's
call that the
hebbian plasticity world
in the hebbian plasticity world again
you have your environment
and you play this game but
you play the game in episodes and at the
beginning of each episode you
initialize this using some sort of
distribution here a normal distribution
you initialize the network
and then you learn you adapt
during the episode you adapt the network
to have good performance okay so
this thing right here these are the
hebian
rules
so you update the network during the
episode and then at the end of the
episode
you go back you initialize the network
again you start a new episode
and you again adapt that randomly
initialized network so
what's actually learned here isn't the
weight of the network
what's learned during training is these
rules
that transform any randomly initialized
network into a high
performing network now of course you you
might just
object and say hey wait a minute
i can just basically hard code the
you know the optimal weights here into
these hebian rules
like my rules can simply you know not
care about the input
and simply output whatever good weights
there are and ultimately that would lead
back to
rl but as you will be able to see in the
experiments they also have some videos
provided that i invite you to watch
you can really see that the network
reconfigures itself
first of all at the beginning it
reconfigures itself to a good state
but then also as the episode is
progressing it continuously
reconfigures itself depending on the
input
so this is the real power of these
hebbian rules in that
during the episode the network can
continuously reconfigure itself
in order to achieve high rewards so it's
not just that
i can go from the random initialization
to a good performing policy
i can adapt that policy depending on
what the input is
so at test time in this habit world
what we're going to do is again we are
going to
freeze the learning rules so you have to
kind of rethink we're going to freeze
the hebian rules but still we're going
to
randomly initialize our policy in each
episode
and then we're going to
change that during the episode okay and
then that's ultimately going to
give us our reward
so that the thing that's learned is just
something different
here you learn the weights directly
in the rl setting and in the heavy and
plasticity setting you learn the rules
to update the weights dynamically
depending on the input
this is a form of meta learning right
it's not exactly but it is a form of
meta learning
so let's see what those hebbian rules
are and you can
as again you can see this right here
during
training so this is one episode
and it always starts with these random
networks at the beginning
and then you can see as you progress
there is structure
emerging and again i'll link to the
videos
and you can see that during the episode
even this is changing and this is
especially visible
on their other example that they have
here like this
this car example so in this car example
during the video you'll see that
now there's a curve like this and then
as
imagine you're a driver like there is a
kind of a left curve coming and you
adjust your mental state let's say to
say okay i don't know what's around the
curve i need to be ready to break and so
on
and then there is a straight piece
coming and you'll be like well i
i see everything you know i can focus on
different things
you cannot reconfigure your state in
order
to adapt to the the observation
and that's exactly what you'll see in
that video is that the weights are
continuously updating not so much in
these
quarter pads to which we'll get later so
these habian rules what do they look
like
these are biologically inspired rules
and they say the following so
this here is the delta w i j
and our perspective of policy networks
is going to be that
this is a neural network as we said
and we'll just pick up one layer right
here and there is going to be
weights right here you know weights from
all to all these are going to be fully
connected networks
and like this and there's going to be
neuron i somewhere here and neuron j
somewhere here okay so neuron i and
neuron j
are going to have a connection together
this thing right here
and there's going this the question is
going to be how do we
update that weight from one time step to
the next remembering
the weights here are changed in each
time step each time step during the
episode we update the weights
so how are they going to be updated
let's contrast this
first to classic reinforcement learning
so in classic reinforcement learning we
would keep these weights the same
during the entire episode and then at
the end of the episode
right we keep those the same and at the
end of the episode we'll get a reward
and then we'll go back we'll look back
and say how do we need to change the
weights
such that in the next episode the reward
will be higher
and in again in classic reinforcement
learning for example in policy gradient
methods
you will actually calculate a gradient
with respect to these weights right here
actually let's let's go into that later
when we contrast evolutionary methods
so the important part right here is that
we change the weights in each time step
so how do we change the weights of
course we don't have access to the
reward
right in order to change the weights the
reward is going to come into play
when we change the rules to change the
weights but during the episode we don't
have the reward
at least we assume we only get kind of
the reward at the end
so we need a different uh method
and the method is going to be the
following right here
the important things in this formula are
going to be so how do we change the
weights
that's dependent on two quantities that
appear
during each time step o i and oj
and these are going to be the outputs of
neuron i
and neuron j so how do we change the
connection that's going to be dependent
on the output of neuron i which is here
called the presynaptic output
and the output of neuron j which is
going to be the post
synaptic output the rule
the kind of mantra here is the fire
together
wire together means that if two neurons
are
active at the same time regularly then
they probably should be connected
together because they already correlate
and you can see right here that there is
a term in this formula
that is o i times o j so
this here is the correlation between or
the covariance
um or just the product
if if we're exact between these two
neurons
and if they are both active regularly
then this quantity is going to be
high and if they're both not active
regularly that
or if one is active and the other one
isn't that quantity is going to be low
and the a parameter here specifies
how the weights are updated in response
to
this so the a b c
d and eta parameters right here are
these
are the learned parameters these are
going to be your
learned rules to update the weights so
these change
once after once per learning step so
once per
so after the episode is done you're
going to change these capital constants
right here including the eta which is
the
learning rate these things right here
these are per step so this is
each step gives you a different oi and
oj
and then you'll adjust the weight based
on that you'll see that these constants
here
they are per weight so for each weight
in this neural network we learn a
separate rule
of how to update that particular weight
so the algorithm can it can basically
decide for a particular weight you can
decide
well if these two things fire together
often i want to
update my weight very heavily in
response to that
okay so if the a is very high that means
the connection responds very
thoroughly to when the two neurons fire
together
that is not the same as to say that
connection should always be very strong
it's dependent on the input so only when
this quantity is high
should the network or should the weight
be updated
and the a parameter modulates how well
it's updated or how um
how how strongly it's updated it can
also be negative it can be zero
basically meaning that you know it
doesn't matter if they fire together i
don't want to update the weight
this particular weight in response to
that so you can see
that you can learn these rules that can
adapt to different inputs
because all of the changes the delta
here is dependent
on the inputs so on the correlation but
also
on the different inputs themselves and
then there is also
a constant right here
okay this it's as you can see it's a
linear
function of the inputs of the oi and oj
and their product so
i hope this is clear that the these have
been
these habian rules you learn abcd and
eta
and that gives rise to an adaptive
network that can
change and reconfigure itself over the
course of an episode
depending on the inputs
and one of the things right here and
we'll get to how you actually learn the
rules itself in a second
but one of the things right here is very
visible as i said in this first
experiment
where it reconfigures itself
continuously but also in this experiment
with this quadruped
right here so this quarter pad usually
it's you know you simply walk in a
direction that's your reward and rl
is perfectly fine at this as well
however
this is a bit of a has a bit of a trick
to it namely
you are always in one of three
situations either you have an undamaged
quarter pad
or its kind of left leg
front left leg is damaged or its front
right leg is damaged okay and you don't
tell
the you simply sample these situations
uh uniformly and you don't tell the
algorithm which situation
it is in now if you look
at if you compare two methods one where
you directly
learn the weights you learn a fixed
policy to solve
you know this is one task right this is
one task
and all of these three things appear
with equal probability
so you have to learn one policy to make
all of this work
if you learn the weights directly and um
you don't have a power like there's no
doubt that like a powerful rl approach
could deal with this task
but if in this case if you just put a
standard
weight learner with this same number of
the same size of policy as the hebian
they compare to
if you put a weight learner on it it
will
not be able to solve this task
satisfactorily what it will do
is it will say well i need one set of
rules that make
me walk as far as possible as often as
possible
so if you can see at the table
i'm already showing you the results
right here
the table right here if you have these
static weights
you can see that it's performing pretty
well
in two out of three situations right so
it what it basically does it says okay
um here is what where there's damage
what it does is it says i'm going to
learn to walk with my left
leg using my left front leg that means
when i have no damage or damage to the
right front leg i'm just fine
and i'm just going to take the hit
basically
where i have damage to the left front
leg because i'm it's just going to suck
so they solved
they solve this like walk more than 100
steps so that doesn't
it since it can only learn a fixed
policy
it um basically discards
the case where there's damage to the
left front leg it takes that hit
in order to be better in the other two
methods you can see it's outperforming
the hebian
rule in the other two methods but this
shows you kind of the
the difference and the power that these
hebian rules
or these generally neural
neuroplasticity might have because
the having one is perfectly capable
of at least in part adapting to
the different situations now you can see
that
is not symmetric also the hebian rules
they learn
to you know there's 860 and there's 440
of a thing that should actually be
symmetric we do expect a drop when
there's damage but
um it's not symmetric which means that
also the hebian rules they kind of
randomly focus on one over the other but
at least they're able in some degree to
adapt
to both and that's because
it depending on the input you know it
has a rule in there that basically says
well if the
if the back left leg and the front right
leg
you know if they fire together then i
want to
um if they if they fire together the
sensors that show me that they're moving
if they fire together i'm going to wire
them together
because that's how i walk you know front
right
back left and then the other way around
and if that's not the case i'm not going
to wire them together so that would be
the situation where you have damage
instead if they are not wired together
i'm going to and
can do this in the next layer of the
neural network wire these other two
things together
you know if if the first thing is not
the case i'm going to wire these other
two things together
to make up for that loss and
there you can see there is kind of this
logic built into
the network now again i know you can do
this
with learning a fixed policy you can
achieve the same effects
the point here is just to show that um
given kind of the same size networks and
so on
there you that there might be there
might be like a qualitative difference
in certain situations again by no means
this is meant to out compete rl or
anything like this
okay so we'll we went
there now how are these rules actually
learned and there we have to again make
a distinction that is completely
separate
from the hebbian non-habian way
okay so the heavy and non-habian
distinction was
do we learn the weights of the policy
network directly
or do we learn the rules to update the
weights
now the question is whatever we learn
how do we learn it and again we have to
draw the distinction
this time between i'm going to say
classic or
even though the terminology is not
really correct classic rl
and evolutionary methods okay
so in classic rl what i would do is i
would
use my weights in order to obtain a
reward
and then i would update my weights
so my delta w would be proportional
to the gradient of w of the reward
okay so in the classic rl
especially this is a policy gradient
method right now
so i use my policy my weights to get the
reward
and then i would calculate a gradient
and
you know usually the reward isn't
differentiable so you have this uh
reinforced trick in order to pull the
reward out and you you can
read all of this up if you look at
policy gradient
uh the basic policy gradient methods but
this here tells me i need a gradient
usually this is going to be the reward
times the gradient of my
fw of my input so
what this means is what this means is
that if my reward is high
then i i just want to know
what do i need to do to make more of
what i just did
okay and the gradient ensures that for
every single
weight in your neural network you know
what to do
so the gradient means that i have an
exact handle
on how do i need to change this weight
how do i need to change
that weight how do i need to change this
weight in order
if the reward is high and because of
this multiplication here
i want to make more of what i just did
and the gradient tells me how
if the reward is low on the other hand i
want to
make less of what i just did but also
the gradient tells me
how that can be achieved i simply go
into the other direction
than i would if the reward is high in
evolutionary methods
we don't have we don't do this gradient
calculation
okay now there can be advantages to not
doing radian calculation
sometimes back propagation simply isn't
possible even if it is possible
and this is maybe the case where we are
now
what we need to learn in our case is
these rules to update the rules and
imagine you have an episode
and that's kind of episode so you have
step step step step and in each step
these rules are applied right in each of
these steps the rules are applied
and at the end you get a reward so what
you need to do
is to back propagate that reward through
all the steps and then through all the
rules
okay and that might be just
computationally not feasible or the
rules
the rules right here are pretty um
pretty easy but the rules might not be
differentiable
you actually have the same problem in
general in classic
rl as well but you know you can cut off
time steps and so on there are various
hacks
in any case there can be advantages to
not having that gradient and
evolutionary methods are a way to do
that
in evolutionary method usually you are
don't train one agent you train a
population
of agents so you have a bunch of these
uh
neural network agents in here
and the way you update the neural
network agent is you simply let them run
you know you let them run your app
the episode so this is your w
one of them you let them run the episode
they get a reward
and then you can do multiple things so
this depends on the evolutionary method
so you can either
pick out the best performing agent or
you can update each agent
according to some rule the goal here
is simply to basically you always
want to take your weights you want to
add some noise to them
and you want to see does it get better
or worse
if it gets better good if it gets worse
not good
okay the difference is without the
gradient you don't have a handle on how
do you need to change
each individual weight all you can do is
basically random walk and observe what
happens and if the random walk
is you know turns out to be good you go
more into that direction of that random
walk so it's sort of a sort of a poor
poor man's gradient method in these
evolutionary methods
again completely independent of what we
learn you can use
the evolution evolutionary method to
learn the fixed weights
and that's what actually what happens in
the table i've shown you
uh below or you can use the other
evolutionary method to learn the hebbian
update rules
as well you can use rl to learn the
fixed weight or the update rules in this
paper they use
evolutionary methods to learn the hebian
update rules
and they compare mostly with using
evolutionary methods to learn the fixed
weights
okay the exact evolutionary
step they use right here is the
following so
ht here is going to be the thing that
you learn
you know as compared to w being the
network weights h
is going to be the hebian weights since
we learn
the hebian weights so how they'll update
um each agent is going to be they'll
take
the hebian weights and this this here is
how you update right this is your delta
h how do you update the heavy and
weights well what you do is
you you perform
n random perturbations so i take my
weights and i
add noise i just add noise okay so i i'm
here
and i just make a bunch of versions of
it
and then i observe how well are these
versions doing
so how well are my random perturbations
doing this is going to be the fitness
fi right here is going to be the fitness
and then i'm just going to perform a
weighted average so this is my weighted
average
of these new solutions okay
so if this solution here did pretty well
and this solution did pretty poorly i
want to walk
you know in this direction and then
again i do the same thing
here from here i do a bunch of
perturbations
and maybe this one did pretty well and
this one did pretty poorly i want to
walk
in this direction and so on okay
so that's how you you'll change the um
you'll change weights or rules or
whatever you want in an
evolutionary method it's
you know it's pretty easy it's easier
than reinforcement learning no back prop
no nothing basically black box optimizer
there are more complicated evolutionary
methods but
no we don't go into those here right now
okay so again i've already shown you
these results now i said these static
weights are also with evolutionary
method
they also report what you would get with
like a
rl approach like ppo you would get
kind of the same thing as they get um
as they get here so oh sorry
this is not the same as the table yeah i
was confused for for a second
this here is for the car environment
okay this is this vision based
environment so
with their method they get like an 870
rewards with the hebian based approach
with the static weight but still
evolutionary method they get a much
lower reward in fact the hebbian based
approach
is about the same as you get here with
an rl
algorithm and as we said url algorithm
more complicated and
if you use like a if you use like a
state-of-the-art rl algorithm not just
ppo
you get a bit of a better performance
but not that much if you
look at if you look at the actual
numbers
so you know pretty cool to see that
again this is not outperforming anything
this is simply
showing that um you can do that
they do a number of experiments where
they go
in the episode and they kind of change
stuff in the episode
and one cool thing here is that they go
and you know this is an episode so at
the episode you
start with a random network each time in
this hebian
setting and then pretty quickly the
rules
adapt for a high performing right so it
it starts to walk it reconfigures itself
and starts to
walk the reward here again it doesn't
have access to that but we can measure
it
of course and then at this step a right
here
they simply go to the weights
and zero them out so they just delete
these weights right here
and only 10 time steps later
it has reconfigured itself as you can
see
right here in order to walk again so 10
time steps later
reconfigures itself reconfigures itself
and after a short while right here
it's back to its kind of original
performance
as you can see so that's i
i'd say that's fairly um fairly
impressive
uh in this very short amount of time
able to recover from such
and such an intervention if you do this
i mean of course if you do this to
your policy network that's statically
learned it's going to be garbage but
i guess the fair comparison would be to
delete the habian rules themselves
and you know so
it's not like it's not like this can
adapt to new situations
or something like this this is still
learned for particular environments
right
but the the point here is that you learn
the rules and this is kind of a study on
neuroplasticity now my question actually
would be
why this diagonal pattern appears and i
have not
seen a like a clear explanation
um especially is this anti-diagonal
pattern it's not so much here in the
output layer right this is the output
layer
there are what 21 actions or so and this
one is this
this dimension um so not that much there
but there
seems to be this rule and this is not
the case
at the beginning right you saw the
beginning you saw at the
beginning it was pretty random matrix
so why why
yeah here pretty random and then there's
this diagonal pattern
i don't know why if you know let me know
i mean it's anti-diagonal maybe it it is
actually diagonal and the forward
the fully connected layer is just
defined as something like wt
times x and um
but maybe this also depends on the
random initialization
but there is no inherent way why a
particular neuron
would you know care about sending
information to like the same
height of neuron on the other side
or is there i don't know i'm so is this
a property of the evolutionary
or of the learning rules it seems
not because the learning rules don't
depend on the position
i'm genuinely confused about this
and maybe you know maybe they've written
it somewhere and i've just overlooked it
though i
they they do reference it they say oh
there's this diagonal pattern appearing
but i don't think they ever say
why it is diagonal
um okay i might just be i might just be
real dumb
yeah so they also you know they do some
more experiments they show for example
that if you just have random hebbian
coefficients
then your algorithm just jumps around
kind of um
in in weight space around the zero point
however if you actually learn these
having coefficients as they do you have
like this clear attractor
here and you have these kind of
oscillating
curves uh when you know
when when you do that and you can see
here in the different situations where
things are damaged and so on
so all in all i think it's a pretty
interesting
study and i think this neuroplasticity
is it's a different way you know it's
unclear to say if it will ever deliver
the the
performance that rl delivers but
certainly there are situations where
such plasticity is desired
and if we can also combine this with
greater generalization
performance then you know we have agents
that can quickly kind of reconfigure
and a lot of work by these this kind of
open-ended learning community
also plays into these roles all in all
pretty pretty cool
uh non-standard way of doing things last
thing the
broader impact statement uh every now
and then we'll look at a broader impact
statement since these are new
just to get kind of an overview of what
they look like so they say the ethics
computer
societal consequence of this book are
hard to predict but likely similar to
other work dealing with more adaptive
agents and robots
in particular by giving the robot
stability to still function when
injured could make it easier from them
being deployed in areas
that have both a positive and negative
impact on society
okay well again this it's it's not
really
giving robots the ability to still
function when they're injured
i first i thought first i thought okay
they train it
when it's fully functioning but then
they damage it during
test time but as i understand it as i
understand the paper
they already train it with the damaged
versions
they just don't tell the algorithm in
which version
it is right now so um
it's not the same as being able to work
when injured unless you've specifically
trained for it
in this case again i could be wrong
about this
yeah in the very long term robots that
can adapt could help in industrial
automation or
help to care for the elderly on the
other hand
more adaptive robots could also be more
easily
used for military applications the
approach presented is papers far from
being deployed in these areas but is
important to discuss its potential
long-term consequences
early on now okay so
let's evaluate the broader impact
statement let's
well the first check to do is always to
simply replace um whatever
their method is with the word technology
okay so let's do that
in the very long term technology
could help in industrial automation or
help to care for the elderly check
on the other hand technology could also
be more easily used for military
application
check the technology
is far from being deployed in these
areas okay i guess
some technology isn't but advanced
technology
yeah so again the rule for broader
impact statements seem to be
you take whatever your method is and you
go up
until uh you find you know you're
basically at
technology or something equivalent uh
because
no one actually i've never seen a
broader impact statement that writes
about
the actual thing in the paper they
always go up like one layer or two
and then it basically regresses to
technology even even though
very few papers actually would be able
to discuss
their particular thing but you know
um and that and then in terms of
guidelines on broader impact statement
this one is missing there's there's
always this um the holy trifecta
so the holy trifecta is you go like a
you know like you're a
you're a catholic uh you go with your
finger to your head
chest left and right and you say
technology good
technology bad technology biased okay
so if you want to write a broader impact
statement go up the layers
technology good bad bias
and we're missing the bias here so
that's you know i'm just following what
these guidelines two broader impact
statements are i don't make the rules
i'm sorry the the hebbians make the
rules apparently
um i'm not having
okay i've i hope you've enjoyed this
paper and this video
let me know what you think check out the
videos that they have i'll link them
and with that i wish you a pleasant day
bye